you know exactly what you're getting
when the Rockets come to your arena the
chances are you can't stop sometimes
they can get a bit overwhelmed
I've been going like this for the last
five years you have a specific goal for
this season to three-peat Houston a team
that many people believe that give
Golden State the best chance and maybe
not coming out of the Western Conference
they really seek out great shots they
share it they're not out there playing
101 but this group right now with how
they were in are physically the activity
level were they going to be tough to
beat four times
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
the Golden State Warriors have now
combined the two stars and the Monstars
boogie cousins is going to be a warrior
there's no way bogie can show up become
boogie over time and not detract a
little bit from what they do in this
room it's gonna get worse before it gets
better
something's all along with this thing I
do Kevin was getting on dream on we're
now passing the ball in frame ops with
reception there's the team that lost a
reason is a really good defender and
then they bring in Carmelo Anthony
their defenses with
you can't lose the federal reason
as a crowd
it appears as though they're gonna be
fighting for a playoff spot cp3 will
miss two to three weeks because of a
left hamstring strain when CP he's been
out he's been carrying that low for that
team starting Center Clint capela is
gonna be sidelined for weeks because of
a right thumb injury I just don't know
how good they are
one night they're pushing it up and down
the next night there was nothing they
have no identity that they if you want
somebody who begins it's a good day
because not everybody gets through to
give voters they really want to see
Jepsen getting pardoned had to play like
the MVP candidate what they did was they
took the perfect coach in Mike D'Antoni
for the perfect player and James Harden
then they said you know what we're going
to reverse-engineer the game of a
brother who
now you have a guy that took a rocket
team from the 10th place in the West all
the wall has moved them back up into
four and five slide he's averaging 36
points per game
right after all public you'll soon start
to see this real Chewbacca's cousins
ladies because virtually impossible
they're virtually impossible to beat
Chris Paul is probably one of the
smartest players that we have in our
game
he has been put in position to be the
most prolific offensive player in the
regulation he's been
the most dominant office of course we've
seen in a long time
James Harden continued this week
splinters
you ask of a player
obviously this is the ceremonial
we've got a few more
[Applause]
this does have a NBA Finals type of feel
I think fans are excited about this
matchup because of that bones Newsies
can score they have so many talented
players you have like Kevin and James
Harden dynamics and when they both play
the OKC there's so many different
storylines that this feels like the NBA
[Music]
again for sex we've been waiting all
year for this